Dr Zakia something which seems on the
surface of it to be very very simple but
maybe not does eating and
drinking past fasting is it considered
to be a major sin eating and drinking
while fasting intentionally deliberately
is a major sin anyone eats intentionally
while fasting it is a m
sin and that person has to Allah subhana
tala and he has to make up for the fast
later on after the Ramadan and this food
whether enters through the mouth
nourishment it breaks a fast or if any
liquid enters through the nose that too
breaks a fast according to the of M
wasallam which is mentioned
in AB volume number two in the book of
fasting Hadi number 2360 where the
Prophet said that when you're doing wo
you snuff the water in your nose
excessively except while fasting this
gives the indication that the water
enters the nose and it enters the
throat and goes into the stomach that
breaks the fast so but natural any drink
any liquid that enters the nose then
goes into the stomach through the throat
that to invad the fast but if someone
eats or drinks unintentionally out of
forgetfulness then the F does not break
and this happens many times the first
few days of Ramadan people are so used
to getting up and eating you know and
drinking water going to the kitchen so
the first few days it does happen with
some people that they forget and they
have the water or they eat not knowing
that they're fasting so if a person
unintentionally or out of forgetfulness
drinks or eats the fast has to be
completed it's not invalidated this is
again according to theth of MMI wasallam
which is mentioned in sari Vol number
three in the book of
Hadith number 1933 where the Beloved
Prophet said that if a person eats or
drinks unintentionally he should
complete his fast and what he has eaten
and drunk it is from Allah subhana
tala and a beloved also said it's
mentioned in MA volume number three
Hadith number 2043 as well as 2045 our
beloved Prophet said that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has excused my um
from forgetfulness from mistakes and if
something is forced on them if something
done out of mistake out of forgetfulness
out of compulsion Allah excuses you so
only intentionally eating and drinking
breaks the fast and it's a Maj sin thank
goodness for the mercy of Allah
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah